The Hulk and Wolverine fight Hulk Vine
in this comic and Wolverine becomes the
Hulk which is crazy all kinds of Hulk
Madness so this opens up with a guy
named Clayton Cortez and undoubtedly you
guys are asking yourselves who in the
world is Hulk Vin Clayton Cortez is Hulk
vain he's basically the result of
splicing the DNA of the Hulk and the DNA
of Wolverine into one person and then
giving that person adamantium and
there's other members of The Weapon X
thrown in there Domino and so on and so
forth but in essence he has an
adamantium skeleton with wolver Reigns
adamantium claws and basically the
unlimited strength of the Hulk this dude
is nuts like it's absolutely amazing I
love his character most of his stories
are trash but this one is not so the
cool thing here is that with this guy
they're watching everything taking place
during Immortal Hulk now we did Cover
Immortal Hulk and this is kind of like
the big battle that took place between
the immortal Hulk and the Avengers which
we only got glimpses of but basically he
dominated The Avengers ures completely
because Immortal Hulk is amazing but the
cool thing here is that once he gets
back to his house with his family he
starts like sneezing and whatnot which
should never happen he's demonstrating
all the symptoms of a cold or some kind
of a virus a person with a healing
Factor would never get that and so right
off the bat they realize something's
wrong now the reason why this matters is
because ever since Clayton Cortez
original appearance and weapons of
mutant destruction from totally awesome
Hulk in the old Weapon X Comics up until
about now he's been hunted by a variety
of different companies all of which are
trying to use him for their own ends
roxon Corporation Weapon X is always
trying to get their hands back on him
again kind of like a modern day wol
reign in a lot of ways and so he
basically sends his family into hiding
but once they're gone Bruce Banner shows
up and Bruce Banner runs into him and he
literally ask him he's like Clayton
Cortez and like Clayton doesn't say
anything and he's like whatever I know
who you are I'm Bruce Banner I'm the
Hulk and he's like you stole my Powers
now one of the things to know is that at
the time that this was going on Amadeus
Cho was the main Hulk and wolver rain
was actually dead he had been dead ever
since the events of the death of wol
rain when he was encased at adamantium
so both of these guys don't really know
the ins and outs of Clayton Cortez the
reality is that he just kind of had
their DNA spliced on to him but they
think he stole their abilities and
that's why there's a kind of back and
forth that goes on here because Bruce
Banner's done enough to know about this
guy's backstory right he was like you
basically worked with eagle star you
associated with multiple massacres on
three different continents and then you
got picked up by Weapon X who turned you
into weapon H the Hulk for rain and then
you got even worse and the response of
Clayton like that is I'm not what you
think in the responsive manner that's
what I used to say and so when the
questions asked like what do you want
the response to bner is like I'm here to
stop you right he's there to try to talk
reason into him and try to get him to
understand like the error of his ways
and so on and so forth Now by this point
in time Clayton's turned over a new lead
Fred's no longer a mercenary he's back
with his family he's got his whole thing
going on but the cool thing here is that
once he starts to sneeze Banner realizes
there's something off about this guy
that he shouldn't necessarily be doing
that but Clayton just pops his claws and
goes after banner and then Banner's like
look man we tried to talk about it right
I tried to talk to you about it I tried
to use logic and reason but you didn't
want to listen so now the other guy my
friend is going to have to help you
understand your place in the bigger
picture Hulk manifests and the battle is
on and it's crazy because like they're
evenly matched basically right they are
evenly matched now the big difference
between the two and this is one of the
things that was kind of finicky about
Clayton Cortez we never got any like
Planet Hulk or World War Hulk type
storylines for him so we never really
saw like the full totality of what he
was capable of more so than that this is
the first time in Marvel Comics that
he's fighting the traditional Incredible
Hulk and Wolverine that was the whole
basis behind the hulkverine story we had
never really seen this before now there
is also the leader who's watching this
unfold the guy does play a role but
we'll keep it to a minimum because in
all honesty you guys don't care about
the leader nobody cares about the leader
the leader doesn't even care about the
leader right this guy's almost as
useless is blackbolt from the Inhumans
but one of the things that the
incredible had the ability to do during
Immortal Hulk we should really just call
him Immortal Hulk because that's what he
is one of the things he had the ability
to do was siphon off gamma radiation
from other people and that's what he
starts doing to Clayton right like
sucking the gamma radiation out of his
body but he unwittingly ends up picking
up whatever it was that Clayton had but
one of the things the leader tells us is
that he essentially infected Clayton
with a kind of gamma irradiated virus
which has now been passed on to the Hulk
it's not going to make any difference in
the story so I don't even know why this
was even being mentioned in the first
place Clayton does come across the
leader not knowing who he is of course
the leader is like the smartest enemy of
the Incredible Hulk one of his longest
running enemies but like who cares cuz
like no one's here to see the leader the
bigger thing is that Clayton just like
chases after the guy and the leader
ultimately gets away but in the midst of
that Clayton looks around because this
like disembodied voice he's like
normally I don't butt in on someone
else's fight like this but I'll make an
exception for Chumps who were biting my
style right so like now wolver rain's
here and so now Clayton has to contend
with wolverin and here's the question
that I would ask you guys right I want
to know you're all on this who would you
rather fight if you had to fight one the
Hulk or wolver rain because yes wolver
rain is just to do with the healing
factor and some claws but L we forget
he's got his Berserker rage and that can
Trump the power of the Hulk depending on
the circumstance and who's writing the
story but as it stands the two of them
are just kind of going back and forth
with one another there is a little more
talking here than you were traditionally
see and a lot of it's just kind of like
Clayton explaining what's going on and
Wolverine just being like you know I'm
aware of what's going going on you know
he's like even running around with those
claws looking like me I got my own body
count I don't appreciate being blamed
for yours and yada y y that kind of
thing but basically the conversation
that he had with banner and then the
fight's on right like Clayton
immediately like just lunges at this guy
plunges his claws through Wolverine and
Wolverine's just kind of like okay right
and so like Wolverine pops his claw and
goes after this guy now this is the big
difference between these guys right and
this it's why the fight is so
interesting here Wolverine's been around
for an incredibly long time right a
couple hundred years by this point so
he's the best there is at what he does
according to himself right and then the
Hulk is just I mean it speaks for itself
right just unbridled rage in a in a
physical form that's green Clayton does
not have the experience of either but he
does have his own experience as
basically a killing machine so it's kind
of cool to see these guys going back and
forth and fighting in this way because
unlike Bruce Banner and really just the
Hulk Persona the Hulk like once he manif
EST it's just kind of savage in nature
right Immortal that kind of thing and
just attacking wolver rain is more
inclined to listen to reason especially
because of the empathy side of things
and he and literally Clayton tells him
like my family's in danger I have to get
out of here and wol Reign's like your
family but and that leads to like
Clayton going after the leader and all
his guys now of course the leader
teleports out and then the Hulk shows up
while Clayton's about to kill like all
these henchmen and like the Hulk
incapacitates the guy because he
literally says like you're going after a
whole bunch of shadow-based guys that's
my job now Shadow base is from Immortal
Hulk and really just from The Incredible
Hulk Mythos but the idea of Shadow base
is exactly what it sounds like right
just a kind of Shadow clandestine
organization operating under the radar
government sanctioned going after the
Incredible Hulk consistently right so
it's really really cool interesting part
of the The Immortal Hulk Mythos but even
though Hulk manages to momentarily get
the upper hand on Clayton this leads to
wolver rain picking him up throwing him
on a motorcycle and getting out of there
because he literally tells him like
you're sick you cannot beat The Hulk
that's not going to happen if you stay
here and you fight him he's going to
tear you apart piece by piece you being
sick it's going to make you slow and
when you fight the Hulk you need every
ounce of strength and speed that you can
possibly muster and so one of the things
he says is that when uh Clayton's like
why are you helping me he's like because
you said the leader was after your
family call me sentimental but that kind
of pisses me off right and then you
basically get a point where the leader
ends up running into Dr Alba the one
that originally made Clayton Cortez they
don't become important until later right
what is important here is that once they
all kind of start putting notes together
right especially wolver rain and Clayton
wolver rain deduces the fact that
someone lured them all together right
that it couldn't just been the leader
somebody else had to be working
alongside the leader which of course we
know that to be Dr Alba at this point
but it's him just kind of realizing they
didn't just happen to run into each
other somebody's instigating this
conflict right and even Wolverine
himself having just recently come back
didn't know anything about Clayton and
just worded kind of reached his ears
that like some guy with adamantium claws
is killing people out there so he
started asking questions of the people
that they knew and the answers started
coming suspiciously fast and so that's
where he's like okay somebody was
feeding me the information that I wanted
to know and that led to this whole thing
the other part of that is like Hulk just
comes barreling through right literally
just comes barreling through and running
and so even with Clayton Cortez
intending to take off the response of
wolver rain is no the Hulk's after
something if the Hulk was after you he
would have just stopped here and just
started attacking us but there's
something else that has his attention
and something else that he's going after
we got to find out what this guy knows
the issue is that as they get to where
the Hulk is the sun's kind of rising and
even he asks like what are you doing
here right Wolverine says like I came
here hunting weapon H like just like you
but now I'm starting to wonder and then
like the Hulk freaks out right he's like
he just turns into like Anakin Skywalker
at the end of episode three right like
you are with him right just like lashing
out right and everybody's just kind of
like Banner calm down man like you're
not thinking straight and he was like
get off me right and just goes after
this guy even when Wolverine tries to
tell him hey man like it's not what you
think the response of banner is I don't
care Banner leaps into the air but
because of the sunrise immediately goes
back into his human state which is part
of the immortal Hulk run right he like
becomes the Hulk at night it was a
really really cool blend of like the
moonight type Mythos right where like he
gains his abilities or at least it
enhances what he can do when it's the
full moon different things along those
lines you know at night time and so on
and so forth but the the immortal Hulk
run was very much designed and in a lot
of ways kind of felt like a horror Hulk
type of run so that's why all that stuff
becomes important but we end up finding
out that like Clayton's family is
actually being or actually just kind of
a staying in an underwater base and he
brings banner and he brings wolver rain
there because it's one of those things
where it's kind of like the enemy of my
enemy is my friend right like something
L us all together right like the leader
whoever he is because you know Clayton
doesn't really know who this guy is like
they all let us together there's all a
particular reason why they're doing this
what we end up finding out and the main
motivation here was to instigate a fight
between all three so that DNA could be
taken and when it was they could
actually modify and adjust the Hulk and
Wolverine to turn them into their very
own killing machines which is kind of
cool because as this goes on like the
group is just like attacked by just
these giant henchmen right he just start
pummeling the vehicle so on and so forth
they snatch up Banner they snatch up
Wolverine and they basically teleport
out right these guys disappear so at
that point it's just Clayton there with
his family trying to figure out what it
is that they're going to do next but for
Wolverine and the Hulk when they're
teleported to the shadow based facility
they're just kind of immersed in these
Nanobots more or less that were created
by the leader in Dr Alba which modifies
them and just turns them into these
raging beasts now that's the technology
that Dr Alba originally used in the
weapons of mutant destruction because
one thing to know is that Clayton Cortez
was the most successful but there were a
lot of other experiments right Robert
Andrews Dave Andrews both of whom are
brothers people that came before that
just kind of like modifying individuals
and trying to make the whole DNA uh
merger work nine times out of 10 it
didn't right like I want to say it was
uh Dave Andrews where like he turned
into the Hulk and like the skin just
fell off of him it was pretty rough it
was pretty wild and and crazy looking
but in this instance between the
leader's intelligence and Dr Alba's
intelligence as well as like their
resources being merged they're able to
achieve their goal of creating a
Mindless but controllable Hulk and
wolver rain both of whom have adamantium
claws and have identical Powers right
unlimited strength and so at that point
they're like go out there and tear stuff
up right show us what you're capable of
and that's exactly what they do they
just start ripping things to Pieces Just
Like tearing everything up there even
comes a point when like they look at
each other and immediately just start
fighting and it's really
dope it's really really cool because in
the midst of all this right like an hour
or so later The Avengers show up on the
scene the problem is that these guys are
fighting in what's basically a nuclear
power plant so the Avengers can't just
like run in there right L they end up
Contracting nuclear radiation and then
just spend the last few moments of their
life suffering an Agony as the skin
falls off their bones so they're kind of
like what do we do here and that's when
Clayton arrives on the scene and Clayton
jumps in so you get hope for
fighting a Hulk with adamantium claw and
a wolverine with Hulk's powers so it's
like Hulk Vine versus Hulk Vine versus
Hulk Vine I don't know exactly how you
would describe this but it is dope it's
just like this gigantic three-way battle
between these guys and it is intense I
mean they're literally fighting for
blood Clayton is trying to like calm
these down or try to talk some measure
of Reason into them but at the same time
he's also kind of relishing the whole
experience right because in a lot of
ways is his first time that he can
really cut loose in any real situation
because he hasn't been able to do that
for quite some time right the other
thing about this is he realizes the
leader and Dr Alba are right over there
watching the whole thing so he charges
after them which in turn brings wolver
rain and the Hulk along with him he even
like fires off one of his adamantium
claws at these guys which is pretty
solid because this is kind of like damn
you're full of surprises like this is
pretty crazy but Dr Alba and the lead in
turn see it as like a successful
experiment they reactivate the Nanobots
and it basically shuts down the Hulk and
wolver rain and their ability to be
controlled in turn she points the
Nanobots back at Clayton fires them off
at him but here's the kicker right this
guy is just kind of like yes like your
Nanobots are what made me what I am but
they merge with me right I control them
they do not control me I'm no longer a
controllable creature and so he's like
it doesn't work right like when they
literally just try to control this guy
it's like like not going to work and
they basically teleport away right they
teleport out of there as fast as they
can because it's the only thing they can
do of course banner and wolver rain end
up emerging you know because they've
kind of returned back to their normal
selves and the Avengers are like hey man
it's cool like we get what's going on
you know everything's sorted out and
they kind of go on and do their own
thing and then the story basically wraps
up from there kind of a weird moment the
leader in Dr Alba make out which is
really strange that guy's got an
enormous head but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
it's a fun story man it's a fun story
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section and I will catch you
all later peace